bonjour à tous nous allons nous
intéresser aujourd'hui hauteur
stratégique de la vente aux deux
colonnes
c'est à mon poste est très
particulièrement utilisé pour lancer des
attaques contre un droit dont c'est très
près à d'assif très intéressant et on va
tout de suite s'intéressait à une partie
qui oppose aux sages philly agapes cas
donc aux sages philly commence par
quatre ces six une 44 des quatre des
cinq cavaliers des deux des proches
quatre cavaliers pros 24 et nous voici
finalement tout de suite dans le vif du
sujet pour la première fois de la partie
il ya une modification structurelle nous
n'avons pas la même structure
la différence se fait ou est bien
quelqu'un allait blanc d'un pion des 4
alors que les noirs ont un pion de
colonne finalement ce sont deux pions
centraux mais celui en d4 a pris
l'ascendant sur le puits en eaux cette
puisque le pion de cette aura du mal
pour le moment à aller en 9,5 et
vraisemblablement il est rare de 6 ce
qui va fournir la case eu cinq ou blanc
cet avantage de poèmes alors lorsqu'on
parle d'un avant-poste finalement on
parle on parle de la dernière case situe
son colloque semi ouverte et d'akron
hommes et semi ouverte pour les blancs
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de purs
blanc et la case s'inquiète une case
prêt à accueillir une pièce blanche
principalement un cavani donc
généralement c'est le cas les j1 qui vit
en f3 qui bondit en 5 par la suite
pourquoi mettre un cavalière de 5
un camion de 5 ça peut porter et d
apporter des attaques contre leurs mois
déjà il faut savoir dans ce type de
structure l'espace des noirs est
inférieure à l'espace des blancs c'est
le pion au sel 26 on s'aperçoit qu'au
sens très bien et noir ou quatre cinq
six cases disponibles alors que les
blancs on est 8
il ya deux cases de plus ces deux gars
de plus aux échecs 60 ça peut faire pas
mal de choses surtout quand l'échiquier
et plein plein à craquer de pièces et si
c'est le cas où aucun échange de pièces
donc plus il ya de pièces plus la notion
d' espace central est importante
ici donc l'idée d'avoir cet avantage
pour nos 5 c'est d'avoir un européen un
espace entre un supérieur qui va nous
permettre de transit et d'une aile à une
autre avec notre armée beaucoup plus
facilement
donc si le combat doit se déporter à del
roc par exemple l'armé blanche aura plus
de facilités à transiter ces pièces de
la halle dames valets le roi que
pourront le faire les noirs si on
apporte plus de pièces en plus grand
nombre
plus grande quantité on obtiendra des
positions d'attac et les sacrifices
seront beaucoup plus facile à imposer
donc ici l'espace entre un supérieur
pour les blancs puisque le plan des
quatre seigneurs des quatre îles
internat frontières alors tout pyros est
lui aura du mal à atteindre la frontière
nous voyons dans la partie qui avale et
17 cavaliers f3 et cavaliers gnf 6 les
blancs on refuse les changes de ses
cavaliers ils savent que leur espace que
l'espace d'art est favorable il ne voit
pas pourquoi échanger les cavaliers et
changer les pièces il joue plutôt aux
cavaliers g3 aussi ce fou des trois fous
des six petit rock petit donc et deux
joueurs se sont développés un petit peu
la structure est toujours légèrement
favorable ou blanc ici parce qu ils
concrètement on peut voir que les pièces
blanches peuvent mieux transit et de
l'aide à ramener le roi donc on peut
très facilement voir un fou c'est un
adhérent g5 une tour se place en 1
peut-être on peut jouer des coups de
consolidation comme ses trois peut être
reculer le fond ces deux là d'amendé 3
l'autre tournant à venir en d1 les taux
blanche à l'occasion pourront accéder à
la troisième rangée dépassé même sur la
troisième rangée par exemple tour des 3
au tour 3 est passée en et 3g trois
ouvrages 3 pour viser le roi noire les
noirs avec leurs structures peuvent pas
faire d
la même chose déjà le fossé vite il peut
pas activé contre le roi le roi blanc
les tours n'ont pas de passage ici pour
passer sur leur sixième angers où le sol
en 5e journée angers pour attaquer le
roi blanc on voit donc sont les blancs
qui ont une possibilité d'amener plus de
pièces au combat contre les rock
que vont faire les noirs normalement
dans ce type de problème si c'est la
structure centrale du pouce problème si
cet espace central les noirs doivent
démoli dans ce centre et essayer
d'imposer les leviers eu cinq ou c5
essayer de s'en prendre aux pions des
captifs c'est ce pion qui fournit
finalement l'espace aux blancs donc les
noirs devrait pouvoir arriver à jouer
ses 55 pour démolir l'espace entre à des
blancs est embauché comme ça que des
attaques se montre contre le roi dont
quatre sont joués à la suite de la
partie dames
en e2 justement ce coût est à coup
multifonctions à la fois on accroît de
notre contrôle à la case aux cinq points
clés noires ne puisse pas imposer de
levier aux 5 à la fois on libère la
tasse d un bon peut-être pour une tour
qui se place en d1 par la suite et puis
comme on va le voir dans la partie dans
la suite de la partie ça permettra un
cavalier d'alleurs de 4 en cas de prise
de pouvoir reprendre de la dame par
exemple et créer des menaces contre le
roi de voir avec cette batterie d'attac
sur la diagonale b1 achète donc
continuer d'amener à environ 17
ils cassent polyvalente aussi pour la
dame noire parce que elle peut appuyer
les leviers ses seins que cinq ans c'est
certes un peu aidé ça d'ailleurs les
noirs sont très bien placés pour appuyer
les leviers c5125 la dame c7 le fou des
six lecavalier des cèpes finalement un
put appui indifféremment à la fois de 5
est à la fois ces cinq la suite de la
partie c'est fou j'ai cinq pour les
blancs pessis et cavalier e 4 cette
fois-ci kosashvili accepte l'échangé
pièce mais c'est pas pour rien c'est pas
des changes inutile de toute façon il va
bien falloir un jour son propre cas
valeur des fils qui est la seule pièce
légère finalement la seule pièce qui
défend le roi noir et blanc cet échange
ne parvient pas pour rien parce que dès
qu'il ya les changer
cet échange a lieu cavaliers pro 4 on
reprend la dame et tout de suite on crée
des menaces contre le petit report le
pion h7
et d'enchaîner menace d'un pro à chaque
match donc il faut faire quelque chose
est sûre kamali à 6 on frappe on prend
cavalli donc on est obligé ici de jouer
des coups affaiblissant alors qu'est ce
qu'on en a elles 5 ou le 6 7 5
c'est catastrophique ça laisse le pion
rn26 la casse faible lors des 5
c'est pas très joli c'est
structurellement très faible ici
quelques choisi g6 s'affaiblit les cases
noires elles 6 et à chis mais en tout
cas ça a le mérite de boucher la
diagonale bien achète donc quelqu'un
joue g6 fou à chis la tour doit ce
rallye tour 8es d'un match 4
donc il y à des menaces qui peuvent qui
peuvent arriver
la dame se déportant h4 on peut
peut-être essayer de jouer qu'ils
avaient des g5 à un moment donné on
apporte des pièces blanches contre le
roi noire les noirs ou du mal à
consolider leurs positions royale et a
apporté aussi des pièces contre le roi
blanc donc c'est vraiment une structure
qui permet aux blancs d'attaqué lors
alors c'est très dangereux de laisser
une telle structure c'est à bien surtout
quand il ya eu aucun échange de pièces
légères puisque à mesure qu'il ya des
échanges de pièces légères et notamment
l'importance de l'échangé des dames
aussi bien sûr ça affaiblit les
possibilités à tapas contraire voient
donc lorsqu'une structure permet
d'attaquer arrow les stratégies c'est
quoi ces modifs pour en défense c'est de
modifier cette structure pour qu'elles
ne permettent plus cette idée ou
d'échanger des pièces légères et des
dames pour atténuer le potentiel
offensif de l'adversaire
ici il ya eu très peu d'échangés des cg
en se léchant ge donc le potentiel
offensif des bleus est vraiment encore
leur faut bessette kosashvili continue
son développement et 6 et espère pouvoir
jouer c'est 5.5 assez rapidement je
pense pour pour ouvrir le centre si on
ouvre le centre on aura des lignes des
colonnes des diagonales qui s'ouvre on
pourra avoir accès au camp adverse on
pourra provoquer des échanges de pièces
beaucoup plus facilement et donc on
sécurisera part cela notre droit avec
les noirs les blancs montrent leur
cavale et angers 5 les premières menaces
commencent à apparaître fou en un simple
tour à des 1 à 6 tours est fan de 20
tours à des 8 km avec les noirs ne s'est
pas trop affolé nice il a joué des coûts
de développement mais ne s'en est pas
pris mais céda pris au centre et là ni
échanger des pièces ni modifier la
structure ce qui a fait le jeu de quoi
sa chimie qui par contre elle parce que
c'est une famille lyonnais elle a placé
ses pièces vraiment on attaque et toutes
les pièces peuvent intervenir contre le
roi noir regarder le fond de schiste le
camionneur g5 la dame en h4
le fou en d3 qui vise bien sûr le roi
les tours qui peuvent pas passer sur les
colonnes sur la troisième rangée en d3
en droit est passé contre le roi noir le
pion koch qui peut alors nhk puis on a
cinq pour repos pour essayer de casser
encore se reçoit noir donc il ya
vraiment un potentiel offensif énorme
contre le roi noir est ici la
combinaison a lieu immédiatement
pour preuve un gros sacrifice de
destruction de l'abri du roi noir puis
on prend fou prend g6 deuxième sacrifice
de pièces de démolition de l'abri du roi
noir on veut on veut vraiment mettre le
roi noir sans armure sans aucune
protection
puis on prend là nous avons sacrifié
avec les blancs deux pièces et pas des
moindres une tour plus un fou très
important dans les attaques et
kosashvili propos dans sacrifie d'une
troisième pièce fou g7 ici on propose
trois sacs utile de pièces jaunes a
l'impression qu'on a toujours autant de
on a toujours plus de matériel à
l'attaqué contre le roi noir que les
noirs peuvent en apporter en défense
donc c'est vraiment la particularité de
ces structures qui permet vraiment de
placer des attaques contre un petit rock
ici on peut pas prendre la pièce si le
roi prend cette troisième pièce trois
projets sap
alors il suivra dame h cet échec
le roi est obligé de de s'extirper de
son abri roi et six cavaliers eu quatre
échecs obligé d'alors d'être 5
damages trois échecs roi prend 4,3 prend
cavalli et on finit par un très beau
match avec dame f3 donc on ne peut pas
prendre ce four angers7
mais la menace d'un match est est
immortel donc on a obligé de faire
quelque chose ici
peter gelb qu'un choisi de faire [ __ ]
angers 5
il s'ensuit dame h 8 échecs os est
maintenant le roi noir va être privé de
son abri et il est en grand danger
dames 1 7 donc on place la dame prête à
effectuer une découverte contre le roi
noir cavaliers f8 [ __ ] en cavalier
échec au roi prend aidant française est
dans cette position
l'étoile et blanc gagner là bas bien sûr
mais les noirs ont obtenu plusieurs
pièces pour la dame ceci dit leur manque
de coordination et la faiblesse et
l'absence totale d'abris du roi noir
fait que les blancs sont mieux malgré le
nombre de pièces obtenues les noirs
contre la dame lorsque l'on à un troc
échange de ceux de cette sorte une dame
entre plusieurs pièces l'abri du roi est
souvent déterminant puisque la dame est
vraiment très une pièce très offensive
contre roanne donc la bride y aurait
vraiment déterminant et si le manque de
coordination des pièces noir est
l'absence d'abri pour le roi noir fait
que
fake c'est impossible à jouer avec anwar
de tenir cette position donc ici il faut
protéger le fond bessette
il choisit de jouer tour des huit tours
detroit ont fait passer la seule pièce
preuve de notre dame contre le roi noir
lastours f3 peut-être torre straw a
touché trois tours h3 tous les coups
sont difficiles à gérer ici pour les
noirs faut que cette tour f 3 échecs aux
ag huit dames 17 d'impro six échecs au
roi g7 d'un prince is fuoh h4 dame cet
échec au roi h6 g3 fou j'ai 5 h 4
le fou pas en faire un tour f 6 donc la
place de ma très et là on en rajoute au
g8 pour protéger 6 h 5
roy prend h5 d'un match cet échec fou à
chis et tous rêvent 4 avec un abandon
des noirs face à la menace tourache cas
précis
donc c'est une attaque terrible qui
s'est effectuée contre le roi noir
une structure qui vous donne un avantage
des espaces central de la sorte avec un
avant-poste de code est très dangereux
jeu trancheuse pour un petit rock parce
que l'on peut amener beaucoup plus de
matériel offensifs que l'adversaire peut
qu on peut amener de matériel pour
concéder décembre les stratégies souvent
dans ce type de structure c'est soit
d'imposer des cessions de pièces légères
quelquefois en sortant le fou s'est vite
avant de jouer ainsi ce parce que si le
fossé 8 arrive à venir 9,5
il va consolider la vraie du roi ou
angers 4 enfin le clouage contre calais
f3 et peut-être quelques fois remonté en
h1 qui a angers 6 pour consolider la
brée du roi donc dans cette structure
soit on arrive à la pause et quelques
échanges de pièces légères évidemment
les changer d'avis
la cerise sur le gâteau mais c'est très
difficile soit il faut percuter le
centre en jour les coûts eux 5 ou c5
pour démolir ce pion à des quatre voilà
donc j'espère que cette partie sur
l'avant-poste de colonne eux vous aura
permis de de comprendre un peu plus les
nuances ligne hors ligne ou sur
l'offensive contre un peu de rock et je
vous souhaite un bon moment mais de
bonnes nouvelles vidéos à bientôt
au revoir
non